My knowledge and experience from both past and present...
...influence how I see the world around me.
And therefore, I get inspired by observing things...
...like a human-built environment or geometrical shapes.
I also receive inspiration from the abstract world.
From things like nature or even the concept of energy.
And when I get inspired, ideas spontaneously arise from my imagination.
Some of which I then have a desire to develop into paintings.
So, I show up at my easel.
A blank canvas is like an eager invitation for me to express and realize those ideas.
To bring my expression to life,...
...I use painting tools to give my hands and mind the opportunity to work together.
For the paint medium itself,...
...I love using a professional artist quality acrylic made right here in Canada.
Masking tape is something I find totally fun and exciting to use as a tool.
And even a regular hardware store paintbrush is one of my favorites.
Using the simplest things is a rewarding creative experience.